hey there good to see you we'll get to
the latest on ukraine in a moment but
first
[Music]
well thanks for nothing you jackasses
so did you hear the hunter biden laptop
is real oh and this just in two so is 50
of cat's hair
less than that i know that's true
i know i know take a breath it really is
amazing after the contentious 2020
election and more denial than charlie
sheen at an aaa meeting the new york
times now admits sure okay that laptop
full of politically damning stuff about
joe and hunter biden is more legit than
m.c hammer at the 91 grammys
that's an old reference
of course this is nearly two years after
an election that joe might have lost
if all that info hadn't been buried by
the media and tech industries at the
behest of their buddies in the democrat
political machine
so now a massive report on the ongoing
federal probe and 100 taxes has
confirmed that yes the infamous laptop
indeed exists
in other news putin is psychotic biden
is old and i collect water from used
water beds
it's delicious
a lot of fiber of course we all knew
this but if we brought it up we'd be
mocked and banned but the new york post
was right all along when in october 2020
they reported that hunter ditched his
laptop in a delaware repair shop back in
april 2019 and it contained enough filth
to make pornhub wish they were christian
mingle
besides hardcore porn films starry
hunter himself
my favorites who's my daddy hunter the
grunter and of course the big guy
the laptop also contained financial
documents and messages between hunter
his family and business associates you
know the kind who still wear beepers
it all showed how the future president's
son used his pop as political leverage
in gaining overseas business dealings
involving everyone from china to yes
even ukraine talk about collusion except
no you couldn't talk about this
collusion the one where the big guy aka
joe aka the scratch and sniffer
stood to make millions off hunter making
it rain hunter was like one of the
strippers he banged he'd show up wiggle
his ass i.e his connection to daddy and
the green would flow he wasn't just a
son he was a table dancer from the vip
room climbing all over the laps of
foreign powers in exchange for padding
his dad's bank accounts makes selling
your nose doodles at an art gallery look
respectable
i wonder what joe has to say about the
laptop now
yeah i remember when a computer used to
take up a whole room and now they got
them so small and you can work all day
on your lap
and
you know i'm not surprised hunter had
one of these things he always had the
latest technology i remember one time he
had this device he could fit right in
your
pocket and i said hunter what is that he
said dad i use that to smoke crack
cocaine
and i said whoa whoa i don't need to
know
what you're doing in your private life
just make sure i get ten percent
perfect
but hey his dad's right after all he
bets everybody knows somebody somewhere
along the line
i bet everybody knows somebody somewhere
along the line
that in an intimate relationship
what happened was the guy takes a
revealing picture
of his naked friend or whatever in a
compromising position
and then literally in a sense blackmails
or mortifies that person
send it out put it online
he just read it in a magazine at the
dentist's office you hear about this
thing now you think joe might see the
hypocrisy and all that everybody knows
somebody who's been filmed in
compromising positions
well maybe so but they didn't write act
direct and pay the other actors in blow
yes it's your son and he was doing the
filming and the acting and also the blow
maybe he does have a future in hollywood
so what in who is being compromised here
the hookers the drug dealers the motel
sixes no it was the biden family hunter
then joe then ultimately the presidency
not exactly a simple case of sexting or
revenge porn i wonder how many people
had to be paid off because of that
compromise situation which is why that
laptop had to be dead and buried like it
was friends with hillary clinton
and it's why you don't know jack about
the others and the sex tapes or the drug
dealers but unlike joe's teeth the
laptop it's real of course it doesn't
matter now does it well it kind of does
would putin have invaded ukraine if
trump were still in office even dems
have asked that question because
everyone knows you need a badass to deal
with a psychopath and putin isn't some
fictional character named corn pop but
trump's not in office joe is and he got
there because a cabal of like-minded
democrats media titans and never trumper
republicans made it so by burying the
laptop like a dismembered gangster and
then censoring anyone who dare bring it
up twitter and facebook suspended the
new york post for covering the story
then they suspended and blocked users
for even mentioning it if you wanted
collusion it was staring back at you
from your iphone meanwhile dirtbags like
the president of iran could spew from
their twitter account without
interruption and now a year and a half
later what do we have inflation
crime perhaps even a world war
don't blame me i didn't vote for biden
but nearly everyone in my industry did
and now we got a war on joe's watch like
so many other things that really really
suck
[Applause]
welcome tonight's guest she's got more
energy than a chipmunk on red bull
outnumbered co-host emily compagno
well i'd love to be his prisoner of war
retired u.s marine corps bomb technician
in fox news contributor jonathan joey
joe
[Music]
and she starts st patrick's day in a
green sweater and ends it in an orange
jumpsuit fox news contributor cat tim
and when this man wears green he's
mistaken for a rain forest my massive
sidekick and the nwa's world television
tyrants
yes yes yes yes yes
emily emily emily emily emily emily how
you doing so good i was saying that
cause i couldn't find my notes
do you remember
what shouldn't like somebody shouldn't
the media like buy everyone an ice cream
cake that they demeaned over this story
not an or anything that it's crazy if
you brought this up you were called a
russian disinformationist
yes and the thing about the media is
that they're so fleeting right they're
they're
their bandwidth is like one day and they
their success depends upon gaslighting
the public that you feel the same way
that you don't remember that they
canceled the new york post for saying
the same thing that they just said last
night that you won't remember the facts
that have been laid out by reputable
organizations like us yes and
they keep gaslighting themselves in
their insular unit because they just
keep reporting whatever they believe
whatever they want you to believe
because they're apologists for this
administration hunter as we know is
still under federal investigation for
criminal potentially criminal tax
evasion as well as lobbying things and
money laundering
think about how much press coverage the
trump family has received for the
inquiries into their charity arm right
and the inquiry into the president's tax
records right every day i see on my quad
that nbc msnbc or cnn has at least one
entire block dedicated to those two
things that frankly are latent nothing's
come of either of them what's your quad
like on the tv you know there's four of
them you guys have them two in the
office
you would come to work you would see i
have quads i've got sixty percent of
mine i don't know um
percent you know uh just emily before i
move on you know we don't use jargon
here so i'm gonna have to ask you to
leave i just
uh there's four of them
that's a joke
ugh
joey this guy joey have you ever heard
of the butterfly effect let me explain
to you
a hypothetical butterfly effect
if the media had not quashed the laptop
biden wouldn't be president
trump would still be president and putin
wouldn't have pulled his idiocy under
trump because psychopaths
don't mess with a guy that's gonna out
psychopath them that's the butterfly
effect do you agree disagree feel free
to call me names because it turns me on
well greg
gregory
yes
he called me jonathan who the hell is
jonathan i'm not i'm johnny that's on
the birth certificate man yeah no but
for real
russian disinformation that's what this
is that's what this was labeled yeah and
the real butterfly effect here is that
russian disinformation went from oh that
that laptop isn't real to uh yeah that
woman that was carried out a maternity
ward that's not alive anymore uh she was
a paid actor right right that's that's
what real russian disinformation is yes
and we just spent a year arguing over
russian disinformation because the new
york post couldn't keep their twitter
handle up listen i mean i hate it guys
if we could reach everybody like it'd be
richer than nancy pelosi yeah like if we
could really reach everybody with the
truth it takes more than just us and for
the new york post to be you know shamed
for this and basically called a a you
know a
sham
institution
that's the real scandal like i expect my
politicians
to be corrupt i really do like you start
at corrupt and you might earn your way
into good faith but like i expect you to
be corrupt and so the whole hunter biden
laptop story of joe biden probably you
know using his idiot son to get money
that really doesn't surprise me and i
really don't expect consequences but
when you shut down a media source who's
reporting on it yeah right before an
election that's what sends the alarm
clock and that is the story that is
putin-esque
but i have to disagree with uh mr jones
cat i don't believe that hunter biden is
an idiot unless you mean idiot savant
because personally and i think you agree
with me we've discussed this over coffee
uh sometimes at a
cafe uh i don't mind the sex and drugs
part i mind that the media banned a
story that is i mean that they
compromised
our
our institutions i can never trust them
again yeah for me it was a weird thing
to block like we already knew that he
did drugs and had sex with escorts we
already knew that yeah uh so i think it
is very strange and also
it's not like they were just really
working hard all this time to
authenticate it it's like i feel like
they knew a little earlier it's just
that now you know we're a little busy
talking about some other stuff so they
want to say oh hell yeah yeah by the way
it's real and again i who cares
who cares why bother to call it russian
disinformation although
yeah i
yeah yeah why bother why bother i was
just thinking like maybe he's upset
because he didn't look good yeah
if everybody thought he looked good they
were sexy naked pictures he'd be like
yes that is me
tyrus
first of all
that can only be true because no one
talks about waterbed water
so that's for one
where does the waterbed water think
about it where does it you never thought
about it you've never even been on one
cat waterbed waterbeds disappeared in
like the late 90s when everyone realized
they ruined your back and your life like
why can you not put fish in there yeah
because there's no oxygen
but that's key talk about a really kind
of artisanal
bottled water i could sell from old
waterbeds i'm not going to because i was
grossed out enough and i'm not falling
for that trap
i see i can learn um
but we need to stop calling it putin
interference we need to stop it's
american
election interference
we saw it in the previous campaign and
they messed up because clinton's stuff
was brought out and now comey looks like
he did the right thing
because now we had americans who
knowingly interfered in election our own
election not in terms of voting stuff
but in terms of information exactly and
that is j and it's so polite
it's putin interference no he's learning
our game
we did it we've done it in other
countries look at our record of every
problem every person we have a problem
with in this world the ayatollah iraq
who would norway although it was like 15
minutes but the point is they're always
american
interference in their elections and we
put our guys in there and our guys end
up being worse than what was there
before in this case they were so focused
on not letting president trump have a
second term that they threw the american
constitution out and everything they
could the freedom of the press to get to
protect their guy they're very good
excellent point
and also not butterfly effect not a bad
movie oh my god i was so good and i hate
ashton kutcher but i love that movie see
i'm the opposite i love ashley kutcher
and i hated that movie cat and i are on
the phone and i love amy smart too
whoever's my car was good but yeah
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else